death stranding is a game about walking
and you're gonna be spending a lot of
time doing it but you're probably
thinking hey is it Norman Reedus riding
a motorbike at the beginning what do I
get one of those getting your first
reverse trike is relatively easy as it
can be found only a few hours into the
main story once you reach the
distribution center west of capital not
City you'll find a rusted up reverse
trike with a dead battery you won't be
able to do anything with it until after
a few more main delivery missions but
wants to make your way to the wind farm
in Chapter two you'll unlock the
generator as a craftable structure
you're then tasked with making the long
trek back to capital not City however
once you make it back to the
distribution center place a generator
next to the reverse trike to power up
its battery and you're pretty much good
to go when riding your reverse trike
it's essential to keep an eye on its
battery meter at the bottom left corner
of the screen
the distribution center and roads you
encounter run on a power grid and your
bike won't drain its battery when
driving on them it's a good idea in the
early game to keep a PCC on hand in the
unfortunate situation you do run out of
juice in the middle of nowhere you can
also be a good Samaritan and leave
generators around to help other players
another important factor to consider
when driving the reverse trike is how
much cargo you're carrying when riding
it if you've got a lot loaded on your
back and on its carrying compartments
then it's top speed will be
significantly reduced it seems to make
the biggest impact when you load too
much cargo onto the bike itself
regardless be mindful of how you
distribute your weight in order to
guarantee it's top speed at all times if
you hold back while driving the reverse
trike you can do what we leave a fancy
trick at first performing a wheelie can
help you maneuver over rocks and rough
terrain when you're stuck the reverse
trike is capable of driving through
shallow water
although doing this will drain the
battery faster however it does have its
limits and it's important to be cautious
the reverse trike is more fragile than
you think and driving off a medium to
large ramp can lead to instant disaster
you can eventually fabricate your own
reverse trike but you don't get access
to that until later in chapter 3 so this
first one is all you get
play it safe when traveling and try not
to get stuck on some rocks or break it
because it's then back to walking the
reverse trike or any vehicle for that
matter also produces a lot of noise
making it impossible to be stealthy
around enemies when using them if you're
looking for the best safest course of
action when dealing with enemies either
get off your vehicle before entering
enemy territory or find an alternate
path around when it comes to mules
they're pretty easy to speed past if you
have to but if they hit your bike with
one of their shock spears it will be
immobilized for a while forcing you to
wait for it to come back online or
you'll have to run away on foot when in
beatty territory you can move the bike
very very slowly and you might be able
to get around the BTS however this is
super risky as BTS have particularly
sensitive hearing
so the second they notice you and the
ground fills up with tar your reverse
trike will get stuck and you'll need to
abandon it however this doesn't mean you
lose it forever
once bt presence dies down your bike
will be right where you left it albeit a
smidge damaged in order to repair your
vehicle you'll need to take it to a
parking spot at any of the major centres
the reverse trike is a critical tool for
getting around in destiny early on but
like everything else in the game it
requires caution as long as you're not
reckless and keep it well-maintained the
reverse trike will make Samms journey a
whole lot easier but as soon as you
unlock the ability to fabricate both
reverse trikes and trucks
feel free to fabricate as many as you
like and drive as recklessly as you want